this lesson we're going to talk about
absolute value equations and how to work
with absolute value equations and the
graph of absolute value equation so
definitely something important to
understand for the new and revised s80
so let's get right into this so first of
all when you graph y equals the absolute
value of x what the graph looks like is
this real sharp v okay and you can see
the vertex or that turning point is
right at the origin but you can write it
in a more general way like this y equals
a times the absolute value of x minus h
plus k and what happens here is that
each and the k are the coordinates of
the vertex picks up the graph and shifts
it left and right up and down so the one
is grouped with the ex though it has the
opposite effect on the graph so like for
this one x minus 1 so actually shifting
it right one that's positive one and
this one has the same effects what's
going up three so there's your vertex
right there and then this two or this a
value is what stretches the graph okay
or you can think of it like the slope
but this is like 2 over 1 so we're going
to rise to run one and you can also go
right two and then run one to the left
because it's symmetric okay it's the
same on both sides of that vertex you
can fold it over that imaginary line
that goes through the vertex so this is
the graph of this absolute value
equation right here now again the way
the absolute value equations work is you
know whatever is inside like say for
example if I wanted to simplify this
this comes out to negative 6 but when
you take the absolute value it's always
going to make it a positive answer so a
positive 6 okay can never be negative so
you treat the absolute values like
parentheses you do that operation inside
and then you make a positive so let's
look at a couple examples so you can do
these on your own and we'll walk through
them together example number one says
for what value of x is 2 times the
absolute value of X minus 4 plus 6 equal
to 10 and they give us some options here
well you know of course when a
multiple-choice exam you know it's
always good if you can just to go ahead
and substitute these values in so let's
just go ahead and do that method so if
we put six and we get six minus four is
to the absolute value of two is two
times two is four plus 6 is 10 so that
looks like six is a good answer but you
don't want to jump too soon because
there might be more than one answer or
you know
let's kind of see if it's the best
answer so negative 3 if we put that in
we get negative 7 absolute value
negative sum is positive 7 times 2 is 14
plus six is twenty know that one
definitely doesn't work and then here
let's see if we put 2 and 2 minus 4 is
negative 2 the absolute value of
negative 2 is positive 2 times two is
four plus six this channel that one
works and the butter disa 6 and 2 which
is what you know end up being the two
answers so letter D is going to be the
best answer now just to show you another
way to do the problem if you want is you
can try to get the absolute value part
of the equation by itself and the way I
would do that I was a subtract six from
both sides and then I would divide by
two because you're kind of going to
absolute value by itself so that cancels
and so now we're down to it the absolute
value of X minus 4 equals two but
remember whatever is inside of the
absolute value can be negative 2 or it
can be positive 2 because when we take
the absolute value it's always going to
make it positive 2 so I would split this
up into two equations X minus 4 equals 2
and X minus 4 equals negative tubes
you're considering both cases now if you
add 4 to both sides here you can see
you're getting six if you add 4 to both
sides here you see you're getting too so
that's how we got the answer is two and
six but again you know you can back
substitute that's a good way that you
know work with some of these problems is
maybe eating a little bit quicker so
example 2 it says which of the following
is equal to negative 2 for some value of
x okay and they give us some expression
to your some absolute value expression
so like say for example for letter A
could this be negative to you know let
me try and put some values in like if I
put 0 in I get one yes we got one as one
plus one is two no that's not negative
two you know you could try and test some
values but this is where understanding
where the you know how the grass looks
can really help you so for example if I
was graphing this I can see this is
shifting left one and up one the a value
is positive ones is going to be opening
up like this this can never equal
negative 2 you see that whereas this one
over here let's look at this one you're
shifting left three because remember
this has the opposite effect in the
graph and down two okay so this graph
looks something like like this yeah this
one can equal negative to see how it's
touching right there okay so it looks
like
could be let's look at letter C just to
make sure it's the best answer this
one's shifting right to and down three
so right to and down three but you see
this negative the negative means it's
opening downward like that has a
negative one slope so this one is never
going to be able to equal negative 2
it's always going to be below that so
that one's out and then letter D is
shifting left five and down one so let's
see left five down one it's opening up
like this right because the e value is
positive one so this one will never
equal negative 2 it's you know it's
going to be above that right so the best
answer is going to be letter B so this
is where knowing the graph can help you
with these problems of course you can
always try and you know put in some
values and test it that way as well so
again if you need to review this lesson
on absolute value equations and graphs
and I look forward to seeing in the next
lesson